who are working hard to bring joy to
others before the pandemic about 43
percent of americans
aged 60 and older reported feeling
lonely on a regular basis and now
many are unable to see their loved ones
at all
so a 10 and a 16 year old in
pennsylvania are helping bring
smiles to thousands of nursing homes
around the world
to help with loneliness nikki batista
has their story
you are unique you are special the notes
written by ten-year-old david gupta and
his 16 year old sister hida
may be simple you're awesome and amazing
but the kind gestures are a powerful
part of their nonprofit brighten a day
the mission to bring smiles to those who
may need them most
we were cheering up seniors making cards
for seniors
but when coronavirus hit and forced
nursing homes to close their doors
the brother and sister duo knew they had
to do something
i just wanted to remind the seniors that
they were not alone in this time of
isolation
and show them that the community cared
for them we started delivering care
packages
coloring books puzzle books and notes
with the help of a gofundme page
hitta and divot have sent hundreds of
care packages to retirement homes
you have a zoom call with your family
even gifting residents devices like
ipads to reconnect with loved ones i'm
very
well how are you dear why was loneliness
such an important
concept for you to address in this
pandemic a lot of the residents in
retirement homes don't have anyone to
speak with and that's why we
wanted to make sure that seniors weren't
you know being forgotten
hidda and devitt aren't alone in trying
to combat loneliness
brighton a day has over 55 chapters
across the globe
with thousands of volunteers spreading
cheer to their own communities
i hope you all like the cards we made
and videos of my piano playing take care
we have volunteers who make cards write
letters
record encouraging video messages let it
be
let it be others show off talents like
singing or dancing
to cheer up the residents 83 year old
helen delaurentis is one of countless
seniors facetiming
with brighton a day volunteers i thought
it was wonderful
made me smile from ear to ear yes
because it was fun no matter how much
time you have
on your hands you can brighten someone's
day it's not
something that requires a lot of time
it's easy to
make a difference
[Music]
for cbs this morning nikki batiste new
york